how do you even start a video like this
maybe this is just me I don't start
things assuming they're gonna be
successful so when they do it's like
it's like a dog catching a car what do
you do last month this channel hit a
hundred thousand subscribers that means
that if all of my subscribers all of you
were to be in one place in one country
and form your own government it would be
the 197th the largest country in the
world between the Federated States of
Micronesia and Grenada I started this
channel with one video and that was
literally all I was gonna make I'm at
Oxford I went to a state school this is
the questions that I wished I had
answers to when I was applying so here
are those answers now that I have them
you guys just had to keep coming back I
didn't ask for this
I didn't I didn't ask for all of this
trouble now I'm getting yelled at
because apparently I pronounced cause
like everyone else in the UK I made a
mistake in my thesis which is gonna be
on a t-shirt yes that's that's happening
and three I've amassed a literal army of
followers God knows why what I'm saying
is it's all your fault that this is
happening of course I'm being facetious
thank you so much of course that is what
everyone says in these videos thank you
I really really like that you like the
things I make that's the simple version
I try my best to make content that makes
the universe better that is you know
hopefully entertaining hopefully
educational and the fact that you guys
watch it know tens of thousands and
leave nice comments even share the video
to people you know what on social media
that's amazing you guys are incredibly
generous so thank you thank you for
subscribing and supporting what I do now
I haven't forgotten as you were the
scene in the title I remember that I
think was when I was doing my room tour
I said if I can find the method I think
this might be a cool subscriber like
goal to reach like a million or maybe a
hundred thousand let's be realistic
subscribers if I can get a footage off
of this as me it's the first wise man
I'll see what I can do we no need to
explain that so certainly in the UK it's
very common that if you
primary school and specifically for me
it was year one so I would have been
five very common to do a Christmas play
some kind of play some variation on the
story of Jesus being born you know the
season and the kids play different roles
so you have the shepherds and the angels
and there's normally a bit of a cat
fight over who gets to play Mary and
it's a fake outrageously fake baby Jesus
schools everywhere in the UK do this I'm
interested actually comment if if this
happens where you are as well and where
you are because I'm always interested in
my how to do stints like this all over
the world
but anyway I promised that I would
upload my literacy play and well I got
the VHS digitized and they actually put
me on the cover I didn't ask them to do
this and not in it very much my role is
the first wise man so I do have a
speaking role
okay I've dilly-dallied enough that's
let's watch this so this was in the
church next to my CV primary school now
I'm not sure but I'm pretty sure that's
Charlie McDonnell I went to primary
school we Charley the dog I'm pretty
sure that he's so in case you missed the
pruning this is
the basic plot of the nativity play this
nativity play is but there's the sheet
bar background who is the grumpiest to
the sheep and I'm pretty sure that I as
well as the other animals go to see
cheese areas all the other animals go to
see Jesus in the crew sees Jesus not
going anywhere I'm a happy she doesn't
have much I got the choreography I know
I know he had a massive crush with one
of the girls but I think she was an
angel with that with this bloody song a
lot of the stuck in my mind oh this is
me this is me there's me in the I think
it's a Santa hat here's the line the
line I had oh my god they literally
clearly just I'm mouthing her lines
I literally mouth my lights oh no I had
a song
[Music]
why wait yes I clearly don't know what
I'm doing
they obviously told me I stand there say
that line I remember there was a window
and I Quitman looked at it was like look
a star didn't think about anything else
I found I didn't bother to learn the
choreography
look at me I'm bobbing off like I'm
riding a camel no oh my god I cannot
blame one man fun fact in my primary
school class say you're me you're a
Charlie McDonnell we also had Jemaine
Douglas who joined us after this who was
a finalist on The X Factor in the UK and
then we also had Matt Pierce who has his
own fan club after being on the Jeremy
Kyle show so many times again joined
after this but there's something in the
water in that primary school you do not
know how lucky while I'm editing out all
the dull bits oh oh it's about to kick
off pretty yeah that's that's that's
Mary hey you guys the fake baby Jesus I
said there would be one support the neck
stars children
where else done oh here here I come
add another line here this is gold I
[Music]
bring you gold I love but I love the
high schoo I bring you gold children as
I say angels I just had this permanently
confused expression on my face I think
very pretty I have just that expression
that's been the entire way through this
play oh my god so there we are one week
we're celebrating me past my PhD the
next week we're watching me singing a
song about riding a camel as a
five-year-old nothing but the very best
entertainment on the Simon Clarke
YouTube channel promise fulfilled thank
you all so much for subscribing to this
channel it's amazing what we have built
together all of us as a community I'm
I'm really proud of what this has become
and the work that I've done on this
channel and thank you for being a part
of that I hope you enjoyed the video I
hope it was if it was fun to see little
tiny infant Simon and kind of amazing to
see just how Rose tint is like memory
spectacles can be if you have any
suggestions for what I could do
four features subscriber milestones then
I'm all ears
thank you for subscribing thank you for
watching I'll see you next time
[Music]